we live in a really interesting time in
that if enough people get angry over the
internet about something
it can create change and quite quickly
now look at these photos and tell me
that you don't have the same exact
initial reaction that i did as well as
everyone else that i've ever shared them
with which is
wait this is this is the tank like this
this whale lives in this small concrete
bathtub for the last 52 years well
that's messed up
same reaction every time and it's
interesting in that we also live in a
period of time where people are as
divided as ever society as a whole it
seems that you can't find one thing that
everyone agrees upon
except for this this is a unique special
moment where every person with a soul
universally agrees that this is wrong
it's unacceptable and yes removing this
poor whale from this small cruel
enclosure
is the right thing to do
and and this is the best part guys is
that it's totally possible and we as the
internet are gonna bust her ass out of
there so here's the situation i am going
to miami with my friend phil demers on
the first weekend of june and if you
don't know phil he's also referred to as
the walrus whisperer and he is worthy of
your time because he is a good guy that
has sacrificed so much and we are going
together to miami to a demonstration on
sunday june 5th in order to spread
awareness to help lolita get her freedom
now
there is this is very complicated
there's a lot of people that have spent
years and years on this um to clarify
we're not raising any money this is no
longer about money guys this is about
enough people getting involved and this
can happen and i'm telling you it's
something to feel good about i
understand that this world has about a
million problems and someone's going to
watch us like we need to fix this we
need to fix that hey listen there's
billions of us and we can all do
something at the same time and i gotta
be honest with you i think that it would
be really really good to save this poor
creature because let's be real they're
sentient beings this is scientifically
proven they suffer i mean they give them
literal ssris and valium and
antidepressants um and you should know
that
we all understand that orcas are a
community species they do not operate
alone in the wild
and where this becomes even more
disturbing is that poor lolita who was
first of all captured out of the wild at
four years old and has lived at the
miami sea aquarium ever since 1970 again
52 years of her 56 years of life
and she has been in isolation from any
other orcas
since 1980
that's 42 years
and that's once hugo her prior companion
had literally committed suicide by
repeatedly banging his head against the
concrete wall until it died of a brain
aneurysm and and this is not uncommon
like this is happening in marine land
right now which by the way phil de merz
was a trainer there
he went rogue and went public addressing
various atrocities that were happening
there and then he became a victim of a
vicious lawsuit of being sued up the ass
by this place called marineland and he's
not guilty of anything his story is
fascinating uh you may recognize him for
having been on the joe rogan experience
podcast five times that says a lot in
fact joe rogan refers to him as a hero
and he really is like he's he's if you
look into his story it's very inspiring
he's someone that did the hard right
instead of the easy wrong and and and he
has suffered greatly for it but he also
has a positive uh mindset and so this is
what we're going to do we're going to
miami and we're inviting you to come
with us we're going to be at a
demonstration on sunday june 5th we'd
like for you to come and we're also
going to do a meet and greet on saturday
june 4th at one of the hotel bars or
something uh follow us on instagram
we'll be keeping you posted as uh we
plan everything out but the reality is
this
again this is a complicated topic this
this there's many people smart people
that have put their time into this and
what we're going to do right now is
bring attention to this issue and i'm
telling you that
the the power of bringing attention to
an issue in this day and age cannot be
overstated because it's exactly why
canada passed
s203 which is prohibiting orcas from
being whales being brought from the wild
into captivity they're not allowed to
breed them they can't use them in shows
and all of this is because of phil and
joe rogan who did a real solid i mean
that's how i learned of phil is by
watching a joe rogan podcast a few years
ago and i was blown away at this story
and and i should also mention that you
should look at phil's documentary it
came out um in 2020 right around the
cove in time and unfortunately because
of all that it didn't get traction the
way it surely deserved to because i
watched it on amazon and it was an
excellent documentary and it's worthy of
your time
um so with all that said like guys
this is something that is totally
possible and i'm telling you right now
if you just create enough noise about
this it will have an effect mark my
words but as of right now here's the
messed up part as of right now
did she's gonna die in there and i was
heartbroken when tilikum died in sea
world i if you were following me since
the beginning you would know i had about
four or five different videos about
blackfish and seaworld
i only have one up now i took down the
others
because uh
the i said some interesting things about
the prior uh ceo at seaworld and once he
quit and stepped down i took down those
videos because i thought it was like the
classy move to do
um but this is something i hold dear to
me like i cried like a baby in blackfish
and i just really want to see a video
of lolita as well as kiska from
marineland um being released and just to
clarify no one's suggesting they just go
dump them in the wild that would they
would die surely um but we are
suggesting in others is it to be
rehabilitated or at least if nothing
else be put into a sanctuary like a
fenced-off cove where if nothing else
they have the natural ocean current
because this be clear spending the rest
of their lives in this small
unbelievable tank is cruel it's wrong
it's not the right way to go and it
doesn't have to be this way um and and
honestly i would like to see a video of
them experiencing being released into
the ocean currents and being around
other orcas for the first time this is
something to feel good about like i
i have some real concerns about the
future
especially in the short term over the
next few years
and i just think that it'd be really
good for everyone to to see something
good happen that we all agree upon
and it's so possible that's the part
where there is a will there is a way
phil has had some amazing contacts with
people over the years and there are some
like i said very smart people that have
been working towards this and all we
need to do now is just put it on blast
because again we're seeing like outrage
culture cancel culture all this
silly stuff in society but the funny
thing is that we can use it for good
like our cell phones are now like swords
like we can just by sharing something
can make thing can make actual change
and again phil demers is the proof in
the pudding of this because of him
speaking out against marineland
s 203 ends up passing as a law that guys
that's because of him and other people
were involved as well but like he's the
reason why that became an international
thing so again uh we will be there the
first week into june it's gonna be a lot
of fun it's gonna be good vibes it'll be
a chance to connect with people of
similar mindsets um as i've traveled
before on tours to egypt and peru i met
some of the most wonderful people in my
life and this is an opportunity to do
the same you get like-minded people
and you talk about something and you
share it together and so here's what
else i am suggesting though um i have
quite literally never asked anyone to
share any of my stuff uh i have videos
on all kinds of topics um
and this is the one time that i'm i'm
literally asking you to share this um if
you are a fellow youtuber or if you know
some other public personality or whoever
like come with us or share it like it's
it's that simple like this is just
clarify we are not raising money like
because that's one of the things is that
people have raised millions of dollars
to get these these wheels out of there
you guys are still there like it's
again it's a complicated thing but what
i'm telling you is that this is possible
it's the right thing to do look at the
damn photos and we all agree it's so
rare to find anything society
universally agrees on which is okay fine
this whale spending the rest of its life
in there and this small concrete bathtub
is wrong and that's the end of it and it
is so possible for change so anyways i'm
going to wrap this up um miam in miami
we're going to be doing a helicopter
right over this freaking stadium i'm
going to be interviewing people we're
going to be getting all kinds of amazing
footage and i'm going to make another
video that tells more about phil in the
situation and where it all stands but
right now
it's about spreading the awareness and
it cannot be overstated on the power of
the internet by just creating enough
people get enough agitated enough change
is possible and it's time to see it done
in a productive manner for something
good as opposed to just something stupid
like we always see over the internet all
that said my name is jimmy corsetti my
channel is called bright insight
follow me and phil on instagram because
that's we'll have more info real soon
but i'm gonna wrap it up there stay
tuned everybody